[Music]
it's official the casting freak
impossible has begun and the internet is
going crazy here are some of the current
suggestions for the Dreamcast's of
everyone's favorite cartoon wait until
you see who could play Kim Possible if
you're new here make sure to subscribe
to the things and give our video a big
thumbs up let's check out the dream cast
of Kim Possible live-action movie kinton
duty as Ron stoppable wouldn't Kim's &
duty be just the most perfect person to
play this adorable boy next door let's
admit it we are all rooting for Ron and
Kim to end up together and over time we
finally got our wish Ron is definitely
an important part of the Kim Possible
story and probably one of the most
lovable characters on the show Ron is
pretty erratic but absolutely hilarious
and we think his real-life version is
Kim's and duty who you might know from
Disney's shake it up whether he's
gunther or kitten he's pretty hilarious
and definitely an ideal candidate for
Ron stoppable we all know Kenton is
amazing at weird random accents and we
have a feeling he'd do an amazing job at
being Ron who knows we might even see
Ron bust some moves and show us how to
bring it on the dance floor if Kenton
gets to play the part of bean Kim
Possible's BFF nolan gould as rufus but
if we talked about ron we absolutely
also have to mention Rufus
although it would be hard to recreate
Rufus as a mole rat in a live action
movie we have a feeling Rufus would have
a much more important storyline if he
were cast as an actual human and even
though that would take away from the
original Kim Possible storyline we have
a feeling Nolan Gould would make a
perfect Rufus he might know Nolan from a
modern family where he plays Luke Dunphy
he's just one of the funniest characters
on the show and we feel like his comedic
timing would be just perfect for this
cartoon mole rat
we always wanted to see what Rufus would
look like if he was human anyways and
Luke would just be a perfect fit what do
you think would you prefer a human or an
animal version of Rufus in the movie JD
Smith as Wade come on we know you see
this connection to Wade is a
communication guru who hardly ever
leaves his room and is always equipped
with some sort of technology Sam so that
Jamie Smith would be an absolute perfect
version of Wade and we definitely agree
let's not forget that James is
constantly posting something on Twitter
that makes us wonder what he's actually
talking about on top of that he has
definitely shared a lot of wisdom with
us over the years and we can't wait to
see more
Wade's hacking talents are also often
put in good use and we have a feeling
Jane wouldn't struggle very much with
having this same skill set besides we
all know Jaden can already act so why
not give him a role in one of the most
exciting live-action movies out there we
can definitely see a modern Wade
spending a lot of his time on social
media zendaya as Monique let's be honest
we all love Monique she's the most
perfect no BS best friend to have around
when you need to keep your head grounded
she's feisty truthful and she always has
something to say
zendaya would be the most perfect
celebrity to play Monique
zendaya has already had several acting
roles that catapulted her into the
stardom she did actually say she wants
to return to Disney and create more
roles for women of color after all she's
the one that always manages to speak the
truth on Twitter so she has an instant
connection with money we have a feeling
most of us would absolutely fall in love
with zendaya as Monique and she
definitely do an awesome job at the role
if there's anyone that should get the
role and upgrade it to a fearless
feminist
it's definitely zendaya come on Disney
zendaya is ready and we're definitely
ready to let's make this happen
Adrien Brody as dr. Dracon we feel like
these two look pretty similar Adrien
Brody could definitely pull off the look
of Kim's biggest arch-nemesis dr.
Drakken is pretty evil and quite jealous
he's always looking for revenge and it
doesn't help that he left school after
he was being laughed at
Kim's dad for one of his prototypes
young people might not know Adrienne but
if you're a movie fanatic you might
remember him from films such as The
Pianist and Midnight in Paris
Adrienne might not have an evil
personality but we feel like this
oscar-winning actor could definitely
pull off this incredible role in real
life just check out how similar he looks
plus we really want to see someone rock
that blue coat as well as dr. Drakken
does as of February 2018 Adrienne's
filming schedule looks pretty empty so
who knows maybe he will actually join
the Kim Possible cast Lauren Jauregui as
she go twitter standin went crazy after
seeing several suggestions that fifth
Harmony's Lauren Jauregui could play she
go the beautiful Kim Possible villain s
has a long dark hair gorgeous green eyes
and she uses sarcasm as one of her
superpowers and if you know anything
about fifth Harmony's Lauren or Iggy you
know that this green-eyed popstar would
be just a perfect addition to the Kim
Possible live-action movie she's a
picture perfect she go and fans have
even photoshopped her in as she go
outfit to prove it
as of February 2018 fifth harmony has
yet to announce any solid touring dates
for the upcoming year after March 2018
so it's safe to say there might be an
opportunity for Lauren to test out her
acting skills for this already iconic
movie
honestly we're here for it hands up if
you want to see Lauren play she go
because we definitely do
Madeleine pets as Kim Possible Twitter
went absolutely crazy when Disney first
announced that they were making a
live-action movie of Kim Possible they
immediately pointed out that Madeleine
patch would be the best person to play
everyone's favorite cartoon superhero
doesn't matter and look exactly like him
plus she plays one of the most awesomest
characters on Rivendell who's probably
just as confident as Kim Madeleine
previously mentioned she loves playing
the role of Cheryl on Riverdale because
of her complexity but imagine what she
could do if she could become Kim
Possible Madeleine was also a
competitive dancer for 16 years so we
have a feeling there would be no issues
with recreating Kim's awesome moves as a
natural redhead she said she was an
outcast
most of her life for it so it would only
make sense to use her look to bring an
iconic character to life and put her own
spin to it what do you think who are
your choices let us know in the comments
that's it for our video don't forget to
subscribe to the thing and hit that like
button for more videos like this one see
you next time
[Music]